Contrôler sa douleur a toujours été un rêve pour l'homme, parce que si on contrôle sa douleur, on contrôle sa peur.
La peur a, entre autres, comme origine le fait d'avoir mal qui est le 1er signal de danger physique.
Certaines personnes ne ressentent pas la douleur, par contre ils ressentent les sensations classiques comme :
le toucher, la chaleur, la différence de température, ce genre de choses...
C'est la même chose que la chaleur, oui !
Mais si l'information devient trop forte, il deviennent insensibles,
comme des super-héros !
Des super-héros...Je pense pas que eux le voit comme ça, surtout si on regarde l'histoire de Steven Pete,
qui a juste mangé - littéralement - un quart de sa langue sans s'en rendre compte...
C'est gênant...
Ça fait des économies sur les courses, mais c'est gênant !
Jusqu'à l'âge de 12 ans il était quasiment tout le temps plâtré quelque part,
et sa plus grande crainte aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir une blessure interne ou de faire une crise d'appendicite
et de ne pas ressentir cette douleur-là.
Voilà, ça sent le mental vlog bien joyeux. Générique !
♪ Générique ♪
Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis toujours malade, et du coup j'avais envie de vous parler de la douleur.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur Steven Pete dont je vous ai parlé juste là, à l'instant,
il est atteint d'un dysfonctionnement d'un gène, du gène S-C-N-9-A...
... oui c'est ça !
Et je vous mets un lien dans la description vers l'interview qu'il a donné à la BBC.
Depuis les années 90, on cherche à visualiser dans le cerveau où se crée la douleur et comment ça fonctionne.
On cherche à cartographier la douleur.
D'abord aux USA, et depuis quelques années en France.
Plus précisément, à Lyon où le neurophysiologiste Luis Garcia Larrea
tente de développer des marqueurs de la perception douloureuse dans le cerveau.
Il a vite compris - avec son équipe - qu'il n'y avait pas un centre de la douleur spécifique,
mais que certaines régions s'occupent de différents aspects de la douleur.
Néanmoins il en ressort que le ressenti de cette dernière (la douleur) reste unique à chaque individu,
à chaque personne.
Une étude de mars 2016 - que je vous mets également dans le description -
a trouvé une information essentielle sur ce qu'est la douleur.
Cette information précise !
L'ocytocine aurait le rôle le plus important dans la modulation de la perception de la douleur.
Donc plus fort ou surtout moins forte en l'occurrence !
30 scientifiques internationaux, qui ont été dirigés par Alexandre Charlet au CNRS,
se sont penchés sur cette substance très mal connue.
Pour faire très simple, en gros l'ocytocine est synthétisée par l'hypothalamus,
et s'il n'y a pas réellement de zone de la douleur dans le cerveau (démontrée par l'étude lyonnaise),
le CNRS aurait découvert une zone un peu anti-douleur ou ''Je stop la douleur".
30 neurones - je fais ce geste parce qu'ils sont un peu plus petits que les autres -
ils décident de libérer l'ocytocine en réveillant autour d'eux - toujours dans l'hypothalamus -
des plus gros neurones, et ils leur disent : ''Allez-y les gars on envoie la sauce dans le sang,
nous on va s'occuper de la moelle épinière, vous, vous vous occupez d'envoyer l'ocytocine dans le sang !''
Et alors via les gros neurones, l'ocytocine est envoyée dans le sang et elle va dans les neurones phériphériques
des régions ou de la zone douloureuse, et il la drogue un petit peu en fait...
Ils font : ''Non non mais ça va, on a plus mal !''
Ils engourdissent toute la zone. Ils droguent la sensation de douleur !
Et en simultanée, l'ocytocine passe par la moelle épinière pour attaquer directement le signal montant,
le message envoyé par les nerfs qui va dire au cerveau : ''Attention on a super mal à cet endroit là !"
Donc l'ocytocine va traiter la conséquence là-haut au cerveau et en même temps elle va diminuer le signal montant.
Et c'est très intéressant car si à terme on arrive à maîtriser ça en médecine,
ça voudra dire qu'on pourra soulager les gens qui, par exemple, qui ont une douleur pathologique !
En attendant,vous pour gérer votre douleur, suivant le type de douleur que c'est, vous pouvez aller voir,
par exemple, un hypnothérapeute, ça fonctionne très bien.
Vous pouvez faire plus simplement des exercices de relaxation, comme on l'a déjà vu dans d'anciennes vidéos.
Oui, ici, sur cette chaîne !
Autre hypothèse : en méditant !
Y'a des scientifiques qui ont émis l'hypothèse, c'est-à-dire :
on s'calme, oui ça n'a pas été vérifié, ils ont dit ça comme ça c'est une hypothèse !
Que le méditation était peut être le secret des moines Shaolin pour se libérer de la sensation de douleur.
Ce qui m'amène à une question les amis : est-ce que vous aimeriez que dans une vidéo
je parle de médiation et surtout des techniques de méditation.
Personnellement, moi je pratique ça depuis plusieurs années, et ça m'aide dans pleins de choses,
également pour faire un peu de tri dans ma mémoire, pour calmer un petit peu le mental...
Je pourrais vous en parler un petit peu mais je voudrais être sûr avant que ça vous plait.
Alors si c'est le cas vous me le dites dans les commentaires, on en parle ensemble.
Je vais laisser quelques jours, je ferais ma petite étude dans les commentaires,
et je ferais ça en fonction !
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu, maintenant je vais aller me soigner un petit peu,
mais vous pouvez m'aider à guérir en laissant un pouce en l'air !
... Non ça n'a aucun sens mais si la vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez en laisser un,
vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir,
puisque le MentalVlog c'est 1 vidéo par jour pendant 1 an, du 1er janvier au 31 décembre,
donc rendez-vous demain à 17h.
Ciao !
♪ Générique de fin ♪